Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Pour ce 4ème numéro de la classe grandeur nature,
je vous emmène en Ardèche.
Au programme de cette excursion :
la descente des gorges de l'Ardèche en canoë,
l'exploration d'une grotte unique,
nous pénétrerons, également,
dans un château fort pour pratiquer
l'escrime médiévale
et nous apprendrons à faire du feu
comme le faisaient
les hommes préhistoriques.
Allez, c'est parti.
Et c'est parti !
Quand on évoque le sujet
des canyons, inévitablement,
on pense à ceux des États-Unis.
Eh bien, c'est oublier qu'il
y en a également en France,
dans les gorges de l'Ardèche.
Des falaises de calcaire qui s'élèvent à 300 mètres de hauteur,
c'est vertigineux.
Depuis 1980, ces gorges constituent
une réserve naturelle
qui héberge une faune
et une flore exceptionnelles.
Les aigles de Bonelli,
par exemple, adorent ces parois,
ils viennent nicher dans les cavités.
Et puis, avec un peu de chance,
on peut aussi croiser
des castors troglodytes.
On les appelle ainsi parce qu'ils vivent
dans des grottes
qui sont creusées dans les berges.
On ne voit pas l'entrée
parce qu'elle est inondée
mais ça, les castors s'en fichent.
Ouh là, je crois qu'il y a un rapide là.
Un rapide, c'est
quand la rivière se rétrécit,
le courant accélère.
Je vous avais promis
un joli paysage, un joli spectacle,
eh bien, il est devant moi, le Pont d'Arc.
Cette arche fait 54 mètres de hauteur
et 60 de large.
Elle est parfaitement naturelle.
Il n'y a eu aucun coup de pioche ici,
il s'est creusé avec le temps.
Pour comprendre,
il suffit de prendre un peu de hauteur
et de faire un grand bond dans le passé.
Il y a 124 000 ans, la rivière dessinait un méandre.
À cause de la force centrifuge,
le courant de la rivière est beaucoup
plus fort à l'extérieur
qu'à l'intérieur du virage.
L'eau rabote,
donc, davantage les berges extérieures
où se trouvent les falaises.
À force de travail,
l'eau a fini par percer la falaise
en creusant une arche
pour emprunter un chemin, plus direct.
Elle a laissé derrière elle
un méandre sans eau,
ce que l'on appelle un bras mort.
Pour le moment, cette arche est unique
mais à l'avenir, il pourrait il y en avoir d'autres.
Regardez bien le méandre à mes pieds,
à l'endroit où il se resserre,
la rivière continue de creuser
de chaque côté.
Eh bien, un jour ou l'autre,
elle pourrait finir par creuser
une nouvelle arche
et prendre un raccourci.
Mais bon,
on a un peu de temps devant nous,
quelques centaines de milliers d'années.
En attendant, nous allons poursuivre
notre classe grandeur nature.
Après les gorges,
je vous invite à descendre
dans les entrailles de l'Ardèche.
C'est très profond.
Suivez-moi.
Il y a 250 marches pour descendre jusqu'à la grotte.
Énorme !
Cette salle mesure 120 mètres de long,
80 mètres de large, 30 mètres de hauteur ;
la taille d'une cathédrale.
D'ailleurs,
ça résonne comme dans une cathédrale.
Écho !
Cette grotte est
qualifiée d'aven
parce qu'à l'origine, on y accédait
par un puits qui se trouve juste au-dessus de ma tête.
Et, quand on descend dans une grotte
par un puits, eh bien, c'est un aven.
D'ailleurs, le mannequin qui est suspendu
à l'aplomb du puits, illustre cette voie
d'accès.
C'est par ici,
qu'est descendu Robert de Joly
en 1935, le découvreur de la grotte.
On doit dire l'inventeur.
C'est vraiment grandiose.
Et dire qu'on ne visite qu'1/10 de la grotte,
le reste est à la disposition
des spéléologues et des scientifiques.
Dans l'Aven d'Orgnac,
on déambule dans une forêt de concrétions.
Des stalactites et des stalagmites,
il en pousse de partout.
D'ailleurs,
il existe un moyen mnémotechnique
pour ne pas les confondre.
La stalactite avec un "t", tombe du plafond
et la stalagmite avec un "m",
monte vers le plafond.
Et quand les 2 se rejoignent,
elles forment une colonne.
Comme derrière-moi.
Et là, nous sommes devant ce que l'on appelle un buffet d'orgue.
Lorsque des stalagmites
rejoignent des stalactites,
elles forment un rideau calcaire.
Alors,
quand on voit toutes ces concrétions,
on se demande
comment elles se sont formées.
Eh bien, tout commence au-dessus
de nos têtes, sur le plancher des vaches,
avec la pluie.
Quand elle ressort à l'air libre,
au plafond de la grotte,
l'eau, retenue dans la goutte,
s'évapore légèrement.
Une petite partie du calcaire, jusque-là
dissous à l'intérieur,
se dépose sur la stalactite.
La concrétion se développe vers le bas.
Pour les stalagmites c'est la même chose, quand la goutte d'eau
tombe du plafond, elle emporte avec elle,
un peu de calcaire dissous
qui va se déposer sur la stalagmite.
Alors, ce phénomène prend du temps,
on estime ici que les concrétions
calcaires grandissent en moyenne
de quelques millimètres par an.
Vous avez
vu derrière-moi, c'est la tour de Pise.
Enfin,
c'est ainsi
qu'on a baptisé cette stalagmite.
Vous devinez pourquoi ?
Parce qu'elle penche
comme la tour de Pise.
On estime que sa formation a commencé
il y a 450 000 ans.
Si elle pouvait parler,
elle en aurait des histoires à raconter.
Tiens, à propos d'Histoire,
suivez-moi !
L'aventure humaine en Ardèche
a commencé très tôt, dès la préhistoire.
Alors, quand on parle de préhistoire
en Ardèche, on pense tout de suite
à la grotte Chauvet et à ses peintures rupestres
qui se trouvent d'ailleurs tout près d'ici
et qui, lors d'une classe découverte, mérite une étape.
Mais si vous voulez en savoir
davantage sur cette période,
il y a un endroit incontournable.
C'est écrit au-dessus de ma tête.
Bonjour.
On a souvent une image erronée
de nos ancêtres préhistoriques.
Tout de suite,
on pense à l'homme des cavernes,
des individus couverts de poils, armés
d'une massue
et vivant au fond des grottes.
Eh bien, c'est totalement faux.
Même si nos ancêtres
ont exploré des grottes jusqu'au fond,
ils ne s'y installaient pas.
Une grotte, c'est trop sombre
et trop humide.
Nos ancêtres vivaient à l'air libre,
en plein jour, comme ici,
sous des abris sous roche
ou bien dans des campements,
le long des rivières ou dans la plaine.
Et puis,
ils étaient nomades.
Ils se déplaçaient, au fil des saisons
et en fonction de leurs besoins.
Cette cité de la préhistoire
n'est pas un musée comme les autres.
D'abord, c'est un centre de recherche,
à deux pas d'ici,
il y a 2 chantiers de fouilles.
Et puis, c'est aussi un endroit
où l'on peut s'initier, apprendre à vivre
comme nos ancêtres préhistoriques,
apprendre à faire du feu, par exemple.
Oups !
Je vais louper ma leçon.
Alors, comment fait-on du feu
si on n'a pas d'allumettes ?
Comment faisaient
nos ancêtres préhistoriques ?
Eh bah, comme ils étaient très malins,
ils ont inventé
non pas une, mais deux méthodes.
Il y en a une où on va taper des cailloux, c'est la méthode par percussion.
Et, il y en a une où on va frotter
des morceaux de bois,
c'est la méthode par friction.
Bon, à ton avis quelle pierre,
il faut pour faire du feu ?
Je sais que beaucoup de gens
pensent du silex, mais ce n'est pas ça.
C'est le piège,
il nous faut une pierre bien particulière,
ça s'appelle de la marcassite ou de la pyrite.
C'est du fer avec du soufre et c'est
parce qu'il y a du soufre qu'on va pouvoir
la faire brûler.
Le principe, c'est que si tu tapes
avec une pierre plus dure, tu vas arracher
des petits grains de fer et de soufre
qui composent la pierre.
En tombant, le soufre s'enflamme
et ça fait des étincelles, super chaudes.
Mais sur quoi va-t-on faire tomber ces étincelles
pour que ça fasse de la braise ?
Il nous faut l'amadouvier.
Tu as cette partie-là,
un petit peu orange, marron clair,
c'est la chair du champignon.
Ça s'appelle de l'amadou.
Alors moi, j'en ai gratté et
je vais faire tomber mes étincelles dessus.
Donc, le combustible c'est l'amadou.
Le comburant c'est l'air et la chaleur,
les étincelles.
Voilà, on a la braise.
On va faire un petit feu.
Voilà, c'est parti.
Puis, tu disais tout à l'heure qu'il fallait un combustible,
mais aussi du comburant
pour faire du feu, de l'air.
Donc moi, je vais rajouter de l'air.
Je vais souffler dessus.
En fait,
contrairement aux apparences,
tu ne m'as pas enfumé.
Donc ça, c'est la première méthode,
la méthode par percussion.
La seconde, c'est
même toi qui va le faire.
Là, il n'y a pas d'étincelle,
la chaleur de départ, on l'a en frottant.
On va faire tourner
une baguette sur une planche.
Le principe, il est très simple.
Je vais me mettre au bord
d'une petite cheminée
et en faisant ça, toute la sciure de bois
va tomber dans la cheminée.
Et, comme je vais tourner très vite,
ça va créer un courant d'air
et si j'ai de l'air qui passe dans un tas
de sciure chaud, là, ça va faire une braise.
On va s'aider, d'un archet.
Et là, la difficulté,
c'est de garder la baguette droite.
Le geste est...
Je redresse un tout petit peu
la baguette, elle est trop penchée.
Voilà.
Accélère encore un peu.
Allez, on donne tout.
Allez, allez, allez, stop !
Super ! C'est bon.
Mon petit morceau de braise.
Elle est toute petite,
mais on va réussir à la sauver.
Super !
Et voilà.
Ouah !
J'ai fait du feu.
Excellent.
C'est la première fois que je fais du feu
comme ça.
C'est génial.
Eh bien, merci beaucoup
Maïlys pour cette jolie leçon,
ce joli partage de savoir-faire.
Merci d'être venu jusqu'ici, de plonger
dans notre préhistoire lointaine.
Et, j'espère que je saurai faire sans toi.
Bah je n'en doute pas.
La préhistoire n'est pas la seule
à avoir laissé son empreinte en Ardèche.
L'Histoire, et en particulier
la période médiévale, a aussi laissé
des traces dans la région, bien visibles
cette fois.
Entre le Xᵉ et le XIIᵉ siècle,
la région, qui s'appelle alors
le Vivarais, s'enrichit.
Des forteresses, se dressent alors, un peu partout, comme le
Château de Montréal, où l'on m'attend
pour une leçon d'escrime médiévale.
Tout cela dans le cadre
d'une classe découverte.
Alors, dans la vie civile,
vous êtes Guy Fabre ?
Oui.
Mais dès que vous franchissez
cette porte, vous êtes qui ?
Dès que je suis en costume,
je franchis cette porte ou une autre,
je suis Arnaud de Rochegude,
chevalier de Balazuc,
capitaine de route
des Corbeaux de Taranis.
En tant que suzerain, je fais le serment
de te protéger et de te venir en aide,
chaque fois que ce sera nécessaire.
Debout, vassal !
En tant que vassal vous emportez ceci.
Chaque fois que je crierai "Vassal,
j'ai soif.",
tu viendras m'apporter, à boire.
Va !
Pendant toute la classe découverte,
vous allez accompagner les enfants
sous ce nom ?
Oui, ils ne seront jamais
que je m'appelle Guy.
Ils ne me verront jamais habillé
comme un homme du XXIᵉ siècle.
C'est le principe de l'immersion totale.
Vassal, j'ai soif.
Manque de chance pour vous, Vassal,
je n'ai jamais pas soif.
Les enfants apprennent plein de choses.
Combien de temps dure ce séjour ?
Il dure une semaine.
Comme on les a fait beaucoup travailler pendant toute la semaine,
le vendredi matin, c'est grand jeu.
Je leur fais reconstituer la bataille d'Hastings
c'est-à-dire que la moitié des élèves vont faire les Saxons et
les autres, les Normands.
Et après, on termine sur une troisième
manche
où là, je prends mes armes réelles,
je me mets en tenue de bataille.
Et, je leur dis "maintenant, vous êtes tous des Saxons et à moi tout seul,
je suis le normand et je vous charge
avec mes véritables armes.
En général,
je termine avec le bouclier sur la tête
et 25 élèves qui me tapent dessus.
Mais vous leur donnez quand même
quelques rudiments
pour manier les armes ?
Ils ont 2 journées d'escrime.
Il y en a une cette après-midi.
À laquelle je peux participer ?
Ah, mais on y compte bien.
Par Saint-Georges, par Saint-Michel.
Pour l'honneur, le droit et la justice,
je te confère l'ordre de chevalerie.
Un homme s'est agenouillé,
un chevalier se relève.
Que ceci soit le dernier coup
que tu reçois en homme libre
sans jamais devoir le rendre.
Va, chevalier.
Je n'ai jamais manié l'épée de ma vie,
mais pourquoi pas.
Ce sera une première.
C'est mon maître d'armes qui vous apprendra,
Messire Mirka de Macross, un chevalier de Calédonie.
J'espère que cette journée en Ardèche
vous a plu, qu'elle aura donné des idées
à toutes celles et ceux qui organisent
des classes découvertes.
Je vous invite d'ailleurs à regarder les autres numéros
de la classe grandeur nature.
Bonne fin de week-end,
excellente semaine à toutes et à tous.
On se retrouve dimanche prochain pour de nouvelles découvertes épicurieuses.